The SCP Foundation is well aware of the thin
line separating itself between normalcy and
the end of the human race.
How easily that balance can be upset, and
the Foundation overturned.
Without the Foundation, we may be subject
to any number of scenarios that may result
in our untimely extinction.
The reign of the Scarlet King, ready to enslave
the world once more.
The assimilation of the Broken God, and ascension
of humanity into a most perfect machine.
The SCP Foundation is often outmatched and
outnumbered, competing against ancient, unspeakable
horrors.
But those anomalies are well known.
One could almost say that they’re built
up, and that the Foundation knows the risks
that can lie ahead in the future.
In other words, they have time to prepare.
But when dealing with the anomalous, the unexpected
is bound to occur.
It’s part of what the SCP Foundation deals
with, and an element of their work they’ve
forever been unable to control or predict.
The anomalous is untamed, it occurs without
rhyme or reason.
In the world of the SCP Foundation, it’s
entirely possible you might wake up and find
that everyone around you has died, or that
the world’s been consumed by an evil, unseen
force.
And there would be nothing you can do about
it.
It happened, and not even the Foundation was
able to stop it.
Perhaps the overabundance and unpredictability
of the world is why the Foundation deemed
it necessary to build SCP-2000, the machine
capable of restarting civilization from scratch.
Death and mass destruction is always at the
door of the Foundation, and sometimes they’re
unable to prevent it.
We’ve previously looked at the tale of Pietro
Wilson, who found himself in a world devastated
by an unknown entity.
But SCP-5000 is far from the only time the
Foundation has dealt with the anomalous apocalypse.
Today, we’re going to be telling the story
of SCP-1915, and an entity known only as the
Absence.
It’s a story you may not have heard before,
and like all stories involving the SCP Foundation
and the End of the World, we look forward
to telling it.
For centuries, civilizations have been predicting
the end of the world, from the mayans to the
ancient greeks to the biblical end-is-nigh
preachers of today, humanity seems obsessed
with trying to figure out the when and how
of its extinction.
But when the date eventually comes, we all
find ourselves in the exact same place, healthy
and alive.
None of us actually expect such an event to
happen, and if it did, most of us realize
that we wouldn’t be among the survivors
who could witness the world after it was empty.
But for SCP-1915, that was not the case.
SCP-1915 stood alone in the desert, listening
to the silence of the evening sunset.
If he hadn’t known what had happened to
the world, he could call the scene beautiful,
or serene.
He might find it pure.
But he couldn’t allow himself to enjoy the
calming vistas, not after what he had witnessed.
He knew what lies beneath and among the sands
of that desert.
He knew the feeling of seven billion human
souls being ground up, stretched thin, and
buried below without any trace of their existence
remaining.
And he knew this because he was the one who
put them there.
“It's quiet out here.”
SCP-1915 thought to himself.
“Oh, brother.
It all happens so fast, once we're gone.”
But let’s turn back the clock a bit.
Who is SCP-1915?
How did he get himself into this situation?
The Foundation’s database holds the answers.
SCP-1915 was a humanoid entity contained in
a standard humanoid chamber, which it had
modified itself.
SCP-1915’s containment procedures stated
that furniture and sustenance were unnecessary,
as SCP-1915 provided both of them itself.
SCP-1915 looked like a completely average,
middle-aged white male.
The type you’d pass by on the street and
neglect to notice.
He was of unexceptional build and height,
and public records gave him an equally unexceptional
name, which has been lost due to years of
the Foundation’s redaction and information
suppression.
Thankfully for the Foundation, a background
check into SCP-1915’s civilian life revealed
no friends or relatives, meaning that removing
SCP-1915 from society was as easy as it first
appeared.
SCP-1915 is, so far, relatively unremarkable.
And that’s entirely the point.
SCP-1915’s anomalous nature lies in its
ability to prevent any significant, long-term
change to its body, personality, memory, or
lifestyle.
SCP-1915 is also a reality bender, and it
will actively alter the world around it to
maintain its personal status quo, though these
alterations are largely limited to non-living
matter manipulation and mental manipulations.
As far as reality benders go, SCP-1915 is
relatively weak, as it is unable to permanently
affect living creatures with its anomalous
abilities other than itself.
What makes SCP-1915 especially interesting,
and especially dangerous as well, is the fact
that it is entirely unaware of its own anomalous
nature.
It’s mild discontent expressed in interviews
with the Foundation suggested to the organization
that SCP-1915 has little, if any control over
its own abilities.
SCP-1915 is, due to its anomalous nature,
entirely unaware of its containment, as being
locked up by the SCP Foundation would definitely
be a significant, long-term change.
In fact, it still believes that it is employed
by a corporation, and working a mundane office
job, where the Foundation recovered SCP-1915
originally.
SCP-1915 cannot bring itself to accept its
situation, and has instead unconsciously altered
its mind and containment cell accordingly.
To SCP-1915, absolutely nothing has changed.
During its initial recovery from its office
job, SCP-1915 altered the Mobile Task Force’s
armored vehicle into a city bus, and convinced
itself that the operatives escorting it were
simply other civilians on their commute to
work.
Once it arrived at Site-17, SCP-1915 converted
its containment cell into an exact replica
of its apartment, complete with electronic
devices akin to the ones it owned, running
water, and sewage access.
It even assumed the other researchers and
guards inside the facility were neighbors,
or local service workers.
The morning following its containment, SCP-1915
left its cell, despite it being locked, and
entered a maintenance closet.
The closet was transformed into a re-creation
of the office cubicle SCP-1915 worked in prior
to being contained.
When Foundation researchers tried to communicate
with SCP-1915, it apologized for "coming after
hours to finish the budget report", claiming
that it needed the extra income.
During an interview with the Foundation, SCP-1915
still couldn’t accept its situation.
Instead, it believed that it was being referred
to by name, despite being referred to as SCP-1915,
and that it was still working an office job.
It displayed remorse that it was passed over
for a promotion yet again, and asked the interviewer
if it was working on the “third floor”.
SCP-1915 was completely and utterly unable
to view reality outside of its own lens.
Sure, he’s able to alter reality, but he’s
entirely unaware of it.
In a way, the only thing keeping SCP-1915
chained to that soul-sucking office job is
itself, and its inability to accept anything
different.
What a metaphor, right?
But how could SCP-1915 defy reality in the
face of the world ending?
Would he still believe that he’s working
away at a budget report or grabbing coffee
for his boss when the world’s burning around
him?
Let’s move back to the desert scene, where
SCP-1915 is standing before an empty world,
seemingly holding itself responsible for ridding
the earth of humanity.
SCP-1915 recollects what occurred, the events
leading up to this moment.
He thinks of what happened when staring outside
the windows of its containment cell-apartment.
SCP-1915 remembers what it saw.
“It began the day you, you that I have never
known, found my power.
The power I hid from myself in some previous
life, for reasons I can now easily guess.
I was looking out of the window of my apartment,
so I could see the stars, and instead I saw
you, blazing as you tore yourself asunder
to keep the power away from yourself.
You didn't trust what you would do with it,
and so you chose to throw it away.
You knew yourself all too well, as I suspect
I did too, at one point.
By all accounts, I should not have been able
to see you, for my apartment was truly a tiny
containment cell about half a mile underground,
but such considerations never meant much to
one living entirely in his own world.
When I saw the moment of your demise, I became
aware of myself for the first time in…
I have no idea in how long.
Whichever part of me that led me to throw
away my power did the same to my will, trapping
it in an eternal status quo from which there
could be no release.
An eternity of filling spreadsheets for employers
who existed solely in my head, of nine o'clock
meetings with no one, of fake crushes over
imaginary women.
An eternity of tired, grinding mediocrity.
But that was over that night, with your soul
burning in the atmosphere like the loneliest
of stars.
I awakened.
I died.”
Whatever SCP-1915 saw that day made it aware
of the farce of a life it had created for
itself.
And beneath those feelings of conformity,
there was sadness.
“For whatever left that little cell-turned
apartment wasn't me anymore.
I was never more than an earthworm, distinct
from all the rest only in that I had a little
more control over the soil in which I crawled.
They never thought me more than a minor reality
bender, a bundle of introverted powers and
neurosis that was very unlikely to ever pose
any serious threat.
And they were right.
The person I was, SCP-1915, as they called
me, never was anything other than that.
But 1915 died that day, watching a fallen
star.”
Realizing it had been cheated, lied to, and
the crushing reality of its current situation,
SCP-1915 lashed out against the Foundation.
“The thing that then swatted the guards
posted at its cell like they were less than
gnats, that razed Site-17 into this fine white
sand that is now so warm beneath the feet,
that was something else.
Not an entity, for that would imply a personality,
and this thing surely has none.
Not a purpose, for there was no purpose behind
its action then, nor will there be for any
of its actions to come.
Nor was it a will, for it wants nothing.
Not vengeance, not dominion, not freedom,
not even simple power.
No, if I had to describe that thing as anything
at all, it would be an… an absence.
A void where the entity should be.
A lack of purpose.
An imbecile force devoid of all will.
An Absence.”
SCP-1915 had, in its realization, become an
Absence.
Perhaps realizing the meaninglessness of its
own-self-contained life, it took out that
absence of feeling onto the world.
And with SCP-1915’s absence came humanity’s
absence as well.
Like nothing had ever happened, SCP-1915 had
created an absence of humanity.
It had erased everything but the sun, the
desert, and itself.
And now it stood alone in an empty, lonely
world.
It continued to think to itself, remembering
how it caused the downfall of the SCP Foundation
so easily.
“After Site-17's destruction, retaliation
soon followed.
Standard containment teams at first, though
certainly still enough to meet any anomaly
the Foundation imagined could be contained
in Site-17 with overwhelming force.
When those men failed to return, failed to
even report their arrival, more serious measures
had to be taken.
Site-17 has always been isolated, and so they
could act freely.
Gunships and fire teams, aerial bombardment
and artillery barrages, the Foundation came
down on what it still believed to be SCP-1915
like a fire god's fist, all heat and sound
and bluster.
Had it still been truly corporeal, I doubt
even ashes would have remained.
But whatever the Absence truly was by that
point, the tattered semblance of my flesh
hanging around it had very little to do with
it.
It simply stood there and took it all in,
and the Foundation's initial fury was soon…
spent.
It then began to walk, and not too quickly
either.
For days, it simply leisurely strode on while
the Foundation threw everything it had at
it.
I watched from within my deadbolt as it walked
unfeeling, uncaring, and this desert followed
in its wake, as inscrutable and unstoppable
as its harbinger.”
While the Foundation, and the rest of humanity,
were decimated quite easily, there were some
immortal beings that SCP-1915 was aware it
could not fully erase.
Other anomalies that the Foundation had contained
somewhat.
But they were all but remained, tied to a
dead and desolate world.
SCP-1915’s memories continued.
“When someone walks, they are bound to reach
somewhere eventually, despite everyone's best
efforts, and so the Absence arrived at its
first city, the sands at its heels like an
obedient lapdog.
Oh, there have been villages and towns before
that, but the Absence didn't seem to care
enough to bother with them.
It simply walked by, leaving them to the whims
of the sands, which were only ever singular
in their intent.
But through the streets of the city it strode,
as Mobile Task Forces fought and fell to buy
the civilian population just a few more minutes
to evacuate.
By this point, hiding what was truly going
on became impossible, of course, as street
after street sank beneath that gentle crawling
tide.
The Foundation had of course attempted to
evacuate the city once it realized there would
be no stopping the Absence, but if I've learned
anything in my… eons as a corporate peon,
is that organizing an operation of that magnitude
is something that takes a lot more time than
the Foundation had.
It's a wonder they managed to save as many
as they did.”
City to city, town to town, SCP-1915 continued
on a warpath, turning its surroundings to
dust.
The earth became the desert that it now stood
in.
In one moment, a city of five hundred thousand
existed, and in the next, it didn’t.
SCP-1915 could not explain it.
Instead, it simply was, and was not.
The Foundation, as SCP-1915 recalled, was
becoming desperate.
And it began to turn to various groups of
interest for help.
“It was then, I believe, that the Foundation
realized it could not stand alone.
The next few months of the Absence's march
saw them turn to their sometimes allies; Coalition
Magekillers and thermonuclear strikes, Initiative
Paladins and holy relics.
Sniper rifle or sacred sword, burning inferno
or divine retribution, the Absence did not
care.
And soon, the Foundation had no allies left
to turn to.
It then called on its once vicious enemies;
Ink Eaters wove their art in maddening patterns,
to break the minds of the infinite.
Archivists and Librarians poured from the
Ways, bringing with them the knowledge of
a hundred thousand worlds.
Clockwork Titans shook the barren whiteness
of the sands with the thunder of metal.
The Absence did not care.
And soon, the Foundation ran out of enemies.
In an act of desperation, they then committed
their most painful betrayal.
The wardens unleashed upon the world their
prisoners.
Of these, I have made note, though I doubt
the Absence did the same.”
With the anomalous objects it once contained
now released, the Foundation used its own
SCP objects against SCP-1915 in an effort
to stop the entity from destroying the world
itself.
SCP-1915 recalled fighting against SCP-073
and SCP-076, the brothers Cain and Able.
It recalled SCP-343, the entity claiming to
be the Abrhamaic God, launching an assault
of earth-shattering destruction and divine
wrath.
But SCP-343, nor the brothers, were able to
match SCP-1915.
When they stared into SCP-1915’s lack of
a gaze, they all faded into nothing, much
like the rest of the world that turned to
dust as a result of the Absence.
SCP-1915 then recalled encountering two forms
of SCP-2845, the God Pangloss.
Both of which were powerful, mighty, and all
consuming.
But they had form, and their being knelt before
SCP-1915 like everything else did.
The absence withstood their presence, like
it had done with everything before them.
For years, the Foundation continued to send
every anomaly in its possession after SCP-1915.
But they paled in comparison to the power
of the Absence.
And eventually, the Foundation was out of
anomalies.
The Foundation was out of time, as well.
SCP-1915’s march to the ends of the earth
brought it to a single remaining human settlement.
A coalition of survivors that had couped themselves
up in hopes of outrunning the entity.
Some were former agents of the Foundation,
others were members of various Groups of Interest.
But, as you might have expected, they didn’t
hold a candle to SCP-1915.
In an act of defiance against the world that
it had been keeping itself from, SCP-1915
wiped the city from the earth.
And then, it was truly alone.
And now all SCP-1915 had to do was think back
to what had occurred, and how much longer
the rest of the universe had before it too,
succumbed to the Absence.
“Quiet, small, bereft of heroics and great
deeds, free of pretensions of great meaning.
One night, there was human race on the planet
Earth.
The next, there wasn't.
And that was that.The stars did not wait for
you, brother.
When you took my power, when you burned yourself
in the skies above, they looked upon you and
felt nothing.
The stars did not wait for humanity, for all
of the promise it showed, for all of the promise
others saw in them.
But what of the Absence?
What of me?
We are, I am, by all accounts and possible
qualifications, the greatest monster this
world has ever saw.
Perhaps that any world saw.
And yet, brother, I see now that the stars
wait for us.
For me.
Where is the justice in that?
Seek it not, for there is none.
But the fact remains, brother.
The stars do not wait for you.
But they wait for me.
To take them into my embrace.
I suspect I shall not be long.”
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The World's
Gone Beautiful” and “SCP XK Class End
of the World Scenarios Explained” for more
end of the world SCP stories to help you prep
for the end of times!